you came I like good morning [__]
[Applause]
you
that's what I'm [__] talking about on
a Tuesday morning January 10th who's
better than you I just took a protein
powder [__] it smelled like 10 gorillas
died out of my [__] but [__] it it's
another day sometimes you got to eat
healthy but your [__] smells [__]
nasty WK & z the dutch station uncle
Joey bringing it to you like a bad
mother [__] out of Tuesday morning we
got nothing but [__] reefers the
glazed buds
cultivate I've been cultivating these
[__] in a wooden trough for
like a week
that [__] is deadly I just been
cultivating it looking at it gone
[__] chopping that [__] bit but
who gives a [__] it's Tuesday you gotta
get your [__] together today's the day
rain snow sleet the sun's out I don't
feel good who gives a [__] suck in a
[__] somebody's gonna steal your
[__] lunchbox meanwhile you one
minute you're looking up the next minute
you're back sit down don't look up your
[__]
look straight ahead catch the whole
[__] party what's going on peripheral
vision you're looking over there but you
actually look at that little [__] do
casing in the corner but enough is
enough Joey what's up with the chili
Channel I just mark this [__]
hey you go
a little smoke into your world to get to
your spirit or swallows out of your
[__] life you understand me you never
want a speedy go smiles around you you
don't want to spit those miles around
you you don't want Chinese people
standing behind you when you're playing
blackjack that's rule number one uncle
Joey I don't even play [__] blackjack
so put that in your pipe and smoke I'm
always dropping knowledge about
something I just hear this [__] you
don't want Chinese people standing
behind you when you're playing blackjack
and I sitting that's that we've got a
phone full day we got [__]
jujitsu I got a meeting at 3:00 we got a
podcast tonight
and that's it and that's that you know
I'm saying that's it and that's that
what are you gonna do but at least
you're starting off your morning with
your uncle you're writing down your
goals you're having a nourish breakfast
you're doing your little push-ups and
your setups and you get out there and
your mind is a [__] weapon always
remember that your mind is a [__]
weapon [__] computers [__] everything
else they're not a weapon you my friend
our [__] weapon but you sitting at
Google and [__] it's definitely let me
help the restaurant who gives a [__]
take a chance come on this dick I'm
saying
everybody want to ask questions and
Wikipedia everyday look at that you
think I got time to be Wikipedia when
I'm blowing those type of [__] smokes
out of my lungs huh the [__] is wrong
with you people
hey listen man the reason why I put this
thing like that is to let you
[__] know that no matter how
bad it was shape your you could always
get your life turned around and tell
these people to suck your dick nobody
was in worse shape than ours I was a
thief I was a petty thief I got arrested
I was addicted to drugs
I slept in [__] different people's
houses with no dignity but you know what
one day I woke up I said what the [__]
what the [__] this is like stealing this
ain't no [__] you don't need to be no
[__] scientist but do we couldn't get
in this world you got it some of these
people are walking around with a
millionaire's are [__] they're not
smarter than you they're not any smarter
than you they just did some they just
got off the couch they didn't give a
[__] what the score was the game you
know didn't care about a party they put
their mind to it became [__] whatever
the [__] they're doing I didn't do that
I just kept snorting coke and cracking
jokes until something busted him here we
are you know I'm saying I'm not telling
you I'm no better than you know be
better than you we all put our pants on
one leg at a time while [__] you
sitting there thinking about ITT Tech
God they got a gun and live your drinks
see what happens when you smoke reefer
in the morning your mind goes into some
weird [__] places but that's what I'm
here to do poos day morning it's one of
those ho-hum mornings how do you think I
feel
I live in California and there's not a
Sun in the sky and it's drizzling I
don't give a [__] you know why because I
still have to take care what I gotta
take care you still gotta dive into the
murky waters of the end of the world and
let this [__] know who's
running things Illinois
boy I said it Illinois the [__] this
collaboration a weave is stuck down here
look at this this is [__] Bowie and
Bowie and Louie I got some Mickey Mouse
the Earth Day from sunset arrabal you
[__] better get down and get
some of that weed over how Bob Platt
pass it's a block pass Lankershim I'm
Burbank let me tell you something you
gotta love this [__] leave this
Mickey Mouse
we're gonna scroll to debt well that's
it and that's God I hope you got
something out about a little chat I'm a
[__] idiot
don't let me tell you something I'm here
and if I'm a [__] idiot and I'm here
can you imagine what a [__] genius
like you could do how nice it is to get
together with my family here and smoke a
ball a couple days a week people wish
they had this [__] privilege they
wish and here we are slowing the best
weed in Cali
making her happy together like a family
that's it and that's that
I'll see you [__] eight o'clock
tonight
tip toe Magoo ready to [__] go beside
that Thursday Cleveland hilarities
Pickwick time whatever the [__] because
his name is eight o'clock don't [__]
around the owner of the club Nick is a
[__] savage down I'm ed Nixon in
Cleveland hilarious so I'm ready for him
and that's it [__] now you
gotta go write down your goals and have
the best day of your life that's all you
gotta do that's how easy this is stay
black uncle Joey loves you and see you
[__] tonight eight o'clock be
there be square if I don't see you
tonight I'll see if there's than that at
the Cleveland calamities all right uncle
Joey love